so we have the graphs of two functions
here we have the graph y equals f of x
and we have the graph y is equal to g of
x and what i want to do in this video is
evaluate what g
of
f of
f
let me do the f of it another color
f of
negative 5 is
f of negative 5 is and it can sometimes
see a little daunting when you see these
composite functions you're taking you're
evaluating the function g at f of
negative five what does all this mean
you just have to remind ourselves what
functions are all about they take an
input and they give you an output so
really what we're doing is we're going
to take we have the function f
we have the function f
we're going to input negative 5 into
that function we're going to input
negative 5
into that function
and it's going to output f of negative
5. it's going to output
f of negative five and we could figure
what that is and then that's going to be
the input into the function g
so that's going to be the input into the
function g
and so
we're going to and then the output is
going to be g of f of negative 5.
g of
f of
negative 5. let's just do it step by
step so the first thing we want to
figure out is
what is the function f when x is equal
to negative 5. what is f of negative 5
well we just have to see when x is equal
to negative 5
when x is equal to negative 5 the
function is right over here let's see
let me see if i can draw a straight line
so when
x is equal to negative 5
the function is right over here it looks
like f of negative 5 is equal to
negative 2.
it's equal to
negative 2. you see that right over
there
so f of negative 5
is
negative 2. and so we can now think of
this instead of saying g of f of
negative 5 we could say well f of
negative 5 is just negative 2
is just negative 2. so this is going to
be equivalent to g of negative 2
g
of negative 2
g of negative 2.
we're going to take negative 2 into g
and we're going to output g of negative
2.
so we're taking that output negative 2
and we're inputting into g so when x is
negative 2
when x is negative 2 what is g
so we see
when x is negative 2 g
the graph is right over there g of
negative 2 is
is 1.
so this is going to be 1. so
g of f of negative 5 sounds really
complicated we were able to figure out
is one because you input negative 5 into
f it outputs negative 2. and then you
input negative 2 into g it outputs 1.
and we're all done